[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم وفي الوقت
الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث وتتفاعل اخرى
تبدا هذه اللقطات من العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو التي ضمت اليوم لقاء تركيا وسوريا
منذ اندلاع الثوره السوريه هو الاول هذا
الاجتماع
الروسي هذه اللقطه تاتينا من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي تعيش واجواء
مناخيه استثنائيه بعد عواصف ثلجيه عطله
الحياه في كثير من انحاء البلاد وهذه
الصور من ولايه يوتا بالتحديد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد تمهيد تركيا بالحديث عن اليه لتسريع
التقارب الدبلوماسي وزراء دفاع سوريا
وتركيا يجتمعان في موسكو بحضور نظرهما
روسي للمره الاولى منذ اكثر من عقد الدفاع
الروسيه تؤكد ان المباحثات الثلاثيه
تناولت الازمه السوريه وقضيه اللاجئين
وجهود مكافحه من وصفاتهم بالجماعات
المتطرفه
عشيه التصويت على منح الثقه في الكنيست
نتنياهو يكشف عن تفاصيل الاتفاق بينه وبين
شركائه بالائتلاف من اغفير وزيرا للامن
القومي بصلاحيات موسعه وزير ثان في وزاره
الدفاع للصهيونيه الدينيه وتوسيع
الاستيطان على راس الاولويات المقبله
حرب اوكرانيا ومسار الدبلوماسيه البعيد
كاف ترسم حدود التفاوض باستعاده دمباز
وشبه جزيره القرم موسكو ترفض وتقول ان
الاقاليم التي ضمتها روسيه وينبغي
الاعتراف بها
يتهموا واشنطن بمنعك من التفاوض بغيئه
الاستنسا في روسيا
للاسبوع الثالث كوسوفو صربيا على وقع
مخاوف الانزلاق نحو مزيدا من التصعيد
اغلاق اكبر معبر حدودي بين البلدين وسط
استمرار التجاذبات وتبادل الاتهامات مساءا
امريكيه اوروبيه لايجاد حلل سياسي وروسيا
تنفي اتهامات الغربيه بتاجيلها الصراع
وتؤكد دعمها
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا ما اعلن من قبل بنيامين
نتنياهو عن تفاصيل اتفاقه مع شركائه في
الائتلاف الحكوميه الجديد التي سيعرض
للتصويت على الثقه امام الاكناسه
الاسرائيلي غدا مما اعلن اليوم تاكيد تسلم
زعيم حزب عظمه يهوديه اتمر بنغفار وزاره
الامن الداخلي بصلايه الموسعه اقراها
لكنست كما زار تعديل قانون لتعيين وبدينها
من جنائيه في مناصب وزاريه فيما يسمح
تشريع اخر لحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه بتولي
منصب وزير سالم في وزاره الدفاع وضمن ما
اعلن عنه كذلك اولويه التوسع الاستيطاني
لائتلاف الحكوميه الجديده والاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد رحنا
عليكم السؤال الثاني كيف سيتعامل
الفلسطينيون مع حديثه عن الاستطاعه
29% قالوا انه سيتم اللجوء الى الاحتجاج
الدولي بينما تحدث
47% عن اتساع التصعيد والاحتجاجات وقال
24% انه سيتم وقف التنسيق الامريكي
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا وان
نتطرى خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا وضمن تغطياتنا
لحصاد العام 2022
تونس بين السجالات السياسيه والازمات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
لاول مره منذ اندلاع الثوره السوريه تجمع
طاوله واحده
تركيا وسوريا في لقاء رسميا جرى في موسكو
بحضور وزير الدفاع الروسي ومشاركه قاده
الاجهزه الاستخباراتيه وقد سبقها تمهيد
تركي بحديث عن اليه ثلاثيه لتسريع التقارب
الدبلوماسي وصولا الى قمه على مستوى
القاده وفي خلفيه ذلك المخاوف الامنيه
المعلنه من قبل انقره وبسببها تلوح بشن
عمليه عسكريه في شمال سوريا
لقاء ثلاثي غير مسبوق في موسكو جمعه وزراء
دفاع روسيا وتركيا وسوريا اجريت فيه
مباحثات بمشاركه قاده الاجهزه
الاستخباراتيه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ذكرت
ان الاجتماع بحث السهول حل الازمه السوريه
ومشكله اللاجئين وجهود مكافحه من وصفتهم
بالمجموعات المتطرفه وان المشاركين وصفوا
اجواء الاجتماع بالبناء واكد على ضروره
استمرار الحوار بهدف تحقيق الاستقرار في
سوريا ولم يتاخر تاكيد الجانب التركي لما
ذكرته موسكو لا يبدو الاجتماع مفاجئا
بالنظر الى تصريحات الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان منتصف شاهد ديسمبر الجاري قال
اردوغان انه اقترح على الرئيس الروسي
بلادي ميرور بوتين تاسيس ما وصفها بالاليه
الثلاثيه مع سوريا لتسريع المسار
الدبلوماسيه بين انقره ودمشق الرئيس
التركي اوضح وقتها ذلك المسار بان تجتمع
اجهزه مخابرات الدول الثلاث اولا ثم يتبعه
لقاء على مستوى وزراء الدفاع ثم وز خارجيه
ثم قمه على مستوى القاده
نيه تركيا الذهاب في هذا الاتجاه كان اول
مظاهرها في شهر ابسطس الماضي وقت هذا وزير
الخارجيه التركيه مولود شاوش اوغلو الى ما
قال انه تحقيق المصالحه بين النظام السوري
والمعارضه ثم عادت شاوش اوغلو وذكر ان
مقصد كلامه هو التاكيد على ضروره التوصل
الى تسويه للازمه السوريه وزير الخارجيه
التركي كشف انذاك على لقاء وصفه بالخاطفي
مع وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد عام
2021 على هامش اجتماعي حركه عدم الانحياز
ذلك اللقاء بين الشاوش اوغلو وفيصل
المقداد هو اول اتصال دبلوماسيين بين
انقره ودمشق بعد انقطاعه عقيدا انطلاق
الثوره السوريه
ينضم الينا من موسيقى
المحلل السياسي والعسكري ومن اسطنبول
البروفيسور الدكتور مسعود حقي جاشين عضو
مجلس الامن والسياسات الخارجيه التابعه
للرئاسه الجمهوريه التركيه ابدا معك دكتور
حقي جاشين هل اعاده العلاقات الى نصابها
بين الجانب التركي والجانب السوري خاصه ان
الرئيس اردوغان يقول بانه لا خصومه دائمه
في السياسه
[موسيقى]
نحن اخوه للشعب السوري وقد جمعت نادي
الاخوه لسنوات من السنوات اريد ان اشكر
السيد قوت انه ودوره في
الوساطه هذه خطوه تاريخيه مهمه من اجل
تحقيقيه السلام
والدبلوماسيه وايضا همم
اجتماع لعمليه استانه بين الرئيس تحت
قياده الرئيس
اردوغان وهذه ستكون جهود بناءها بعد 11
عاما من الجهد همم خطوه مهمه هي تهدفه الى
مشكله اللاجئين هو ايضا مواجهه المجموعات
الارهابيه المتطرفه وعلى اثر الاجتماع
اعتقد انه سيكون هناك خطوات تبنى جديده
وحوار بين همم هذه
اطراف الثلاثه عندما مسعود ما طبيعه هذه
الخطوات البناء التي تتحدث عنها يعني
القضايا شائكه حل القضيه السوريه قضيه
اللاجئين موضوع ما تعتبره تركيا ارهابا هل
سيتم حل كل هذه القضايا ما امكانيه حلها
بالاساس
انا يحدوني الامل اتجاه هذه العمليه يجب
ان يتم تامين الحدود
المتاخمه للدوله السوريه بما يحفظ اراضي
همم سياده الاراضي السوريه ومساعده عوده
المواطنين اللاجئين السوريين ايضا النقطه
الثالثه محاوله مواجهه المجموعات
الارهابيه مثل الحزب العمال همم تحت
المنطقه الامنه هذا ايضا سيكون عملنا مع
الروس ومع نظرنا السوريين علينا ان نتذكر
انه هنالك اربع همم ملايين لاجئ سوري
هنالك
هنا هنا
عن طريق الامم المتحده ايضا توفروا
الممرات الامنه والممرات الانسانيه وتمنع
الهجره الجماعيه نحو اوروبا هذا يعني انه
علينا
النمنعه
همم وفاه
المهاجرين السوريين في البحر عن طريق
الاستفاده من مبادرات الامم المتحده
الروسي وما الذي تحققه روسيا من هذا
التقارب
عارفين
انه علينا ان نرى هذا الاجتماع جميعا في
ضوئي العلاقه الروسيه التركيه نعرف الجميع
ان هنالك بعض الاختلافات احيانا بين انقره
وموسكو هذه الخطوه وهذا الاجتماع مهمه جدا
من اجل تحسين العلاقات الثنائي الثنائيه
وخاصه في الارض بنظر الاعتبار الازمه
الاوكرانيه وازمه
الطاقه
جديده للتقارب بين البلدين وايضا اشتراك
دمشق في هذا
الاستقرائي والسلام ما في الشرق الاوسط
هذا هو السياق الذي ياتي في هذا الاجتماع
ولكن ما الذي تريده روسيا في المقابل سيد
اندري
انا هنالك ايام
اتفاق بين روسيا وتركيا لان كل البلدين
متماني بتحقيق الاستقرار في سوريا وتحقيق
السلام ايضا لذلك اعتقد ان الهدف الاساسي
لروسيا هو تحت
ايجاد حل سياسي
لازمه هناك وايضا
جعل هذه الاجزاء التي ما تزال ربما تشهدها
فيها صراع في سوريا
اراضي سوريا الدوله
المعارضه السوريه كيف تركيا بين علاقتها
بالنظام وبالعاده في نفس الوقت
اوكي
يعني
ايضا يجب ان نعزيزا ونبني الثقه بيننا
اعتقد اننا يحدون الامل في
مسالتي تعزيزي هذه العلاقه انا اوافق مع
ضيفكم من موسكو
الرئيس
الروسي والرئيس التركي بها
نعم نعم
السؤال هذا
علينا ان ننظر الى الصوره الاكبر على
الحكومه ان تفهم ان تعزيز الامن والسلام
يجب ان ياتي على الاساسي الاحترام
المتبادل واعطاء الحقوق هم همم مواطنون
السوريون وليس مواطنين تركيين ايضا تاسيس
في بوتيا دوري اسباني الاحترام المشترك
بين المعارضه
والحكومه يعزز من الشعور الاخوه بين
المواطنين
ما امكانيه حل هذه القضايا العالقه وهي
كثيره بين الجانبين السوري والتركي
بثلاثه دون اعتراض من قبل القوى الاقليميه
والدوليه اللاعبه او الفاعله على الارض
السوريه
اللي همم نتوصل الى
تخمينات حول مستقبل سوريا السياسيه لكن
اعتقد ان كلى الطرفين ويجب ان ناخذ بالنظر
الاعتبار ايضا موقف ايران لان ايران هي
همم طرف فعال في سوريا بالتالي اعتقد انه
هنالك احتماليه
باننا قد نرى نوع من الحل السياسي السلميه
عن
قد يشرق المعارضه السوريه في ضمن في نظام
الحكم السوري او العمليه السياسيه اعتقد
ان سوريا وتركيا وروسيا وايران بامكانهم
ان يروا او يجددوا الحل الحقيقي للازمه
السوريه شكرا
للرئاسه التركيه
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل وضع رئيس الوزراء المكلف اللمسات
الاخيره على اتفاقيه تشكيل حكومه توصف
بالاكثر يمينيه في تاريخ اسرائيل نتنياهو
اكد ان حكومته المرتقبه ستضع التوسع
الاستيطاني في الضفه الغربيه على راس
اولوياتها في الاثناء يصدق الكنيست على
توسيع صلاحيات اليمين المتطرف او اليمني
المتطرف بنغفر في منصب وزير الامن القومي
ليومهد بذلك الطريق للتصويت غدا على كامل
تشكيله الحكومه
يمينيه دينيه اصوليه هكذا تعرف في اسرائيل
هي السادسه حكومات زعيم حزب الكود بنيامين
نتنياهو والتي تنشد ثقه الكنيست
تمهيد لذلك قدم رئيس الحكومه المكلف الى
البرلمان اتفاقياته مع شركائه في الائتلاف
الحكومي
ائتلاف بدا تتضح طبيعته واجدته يكفي انه
يضم في عضويته زعيم
الذي صدق الكنيست على توسيع صلاحيته كوزير
للامن القومي في الحكومه المقبله ذاك واحد
من تعديلات قانونيه تمكن نتنياهو من توقيع
الاتفاقيات الاختلافيه مع شركائه من
الاحزاب الصهيونيه الدينيه فمثلا جرى
تعديل قانون الحكومه لتعيين نواب دينه من
جنائيه في مناصبها وزاريه
كما يسمح تشريع اخر تم اقراره لحزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه المؤيد للاستيطان بتولي
منصب وزير ثان في وزاره الدفاع
هكذا يخطوا نتنياهو اخر خطوات عودته
السياسيه على راس واحده من اكثر الحكومات
يمنيه في تاريخ اسرائيل
وكمن لا يطيق صبرا يستبق التنصيب بتعهده
ان يضع توسيع الاستيطان في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله على راسي اولوياته
حكومته يقول ان حكومته ستعمل على تعزيز
وتطوير الاستيطان في جميع انحاء ما سماها
ارض اسرائيل في الجليل والنقب والجولان
وظيفه الغربيه
ويضيف بان هذا حق حصري للشعب اليهودي لا
جدال فيه وفق تعبيره يؤكد كلامه مخاوف
محليه ودوليه من ازدياد وتيره الاستيطان
في ظل ما توصف باكثر حكومات اسرائيل
يمينيه وتطرفها
تضم احزاب المتشدده مثل العظمه اليهوديه
بزعامه اثمار
وصهيونيات الدينيه بقياده بت اسرائيل
سمواترج وشاس برئاسه اريادر
رئيس الحكومه المنتهيه ولايته يا ايرلا
بيد الاسرائيليين من حكومه التي قال انها
خطيره ومتطرفه وان رئيسها ضعيف وفقد
السيطره عليها حتى قبل تنصيبها
غيره من قاده المعارضه المستقبليه
يتعاهدون بالعمل ضد حكومه يخشون انها قد
تحاول اسرائيل الى دوله دينيه ثم تقلق
تثيره تركيبه الحكومه في واشنطن بسبب
المواقف المتطرفه لعدد من اعضائها قاده
يهود الامريكيون ابداوا مخاوف من ان تلك
النزعه العنصريه ستعرقل دعم جاريهم
لاسرائيل بشكل خطير
انضم الينا من حيفا جوني منصور الكاتب
المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه اهلا بك سيد
جوني الخطوط العريضه التي اعلنتها الحكومه
اي مؤشر تعطي حول الاجراءات التي ستتخذها
على الارض بحق الفلسطينيين
الاجراءات فعليه تتعلق
بتفشي الاستيطان
وانتشاره ليس فقط في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله وانما ايضا في مواقع اخرى من
فلسطين التاريخيه من الجليل
والنقب ومواقع اخرى هذا بطبيعه الحال مؤشر
جدا خطير لان كل الاتفاقيات التي وقعها
حزب ان يكون وهو الحزب الاكبر ورئيسه
بنيامين نتنياهو المكلف بتشكيل الحكومه
جديده لم يتطرق بالمطلق الى مسار سياسي مع
الفلسطينيين بل انه يكرر هذه الاتفاقيات
في مقدمتها وفي سلم الاولويات للاستيطان
الشامل كحق تاريخي للشعب اليهودي فقط دون
غيره هذا بطبيعه الحال
الاجواء بشكل كبير جدا بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين بشكل
يعني التوسع الاستيطاني كان يجري سابقا في
ظل كل الحكومات وان لم يكن بطريقه معلنه
بانه اولويه ما الذي اختلف هذه المره مع
هذه الحكومه
اولا اختلف بان هناك اكثر من 60 بؤره
استيطانيه لم تكن مشرع من قبل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه علما ان كل الاستيطان هو غير
شرعي بالمفهوم الدولي وبالنسبه ايضا
للفلسطينيين لكن بالحد الادنى بالنسبه لي
الحكومه الاسرائيليه سيتم سيتم مباشره في
الجلسه الاولى كما رشح عن وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ستتم عمليه هذه المستوطنات
ماذا يعني ذلك تزويد هذه المستوطنات بكل
الخدمات وفي مقدمتها الكهرباء والماء
وشبكات الصرف الصحي والطرق المباشر التي
تصل اليها وهي طرق الالتفافيه تؤدي
بالتالي الى مصادره مساحات كبيره مما تبقى
من الاراضي الفلسطينيه القريبه من هذه
البؤر الاستيطانيه طيب دقيقه لو سمحت تفضل
وتوسيع توسيع المستوطنات القائمه بشكل خاص
بدلائع مختلفه منها التزايد الطبيعي
للسكان ومنها ايضا انتقال مجموعات وشرائح
كبيره من
الشباب اليهود المتطرف في مواقع مختلفه من
اسرائيل للسكن في هذه المستوطنات شكرا لك
جوني منصور الكاتب المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
الى ملف الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث ازدادت
وتيره حديث المسؤولين الروس والاوكرانيين
عن استعدادهم للتفاوض لكن الشروط التي
يضعها كل طرف للمشاركه في هذه المفاوضات
تجعل احتمالات عقادها في المستقبل القريب
مستبعده في احدث المواقف اتهم وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه الولايات المتحده بعدم
السماح الى اوكرانيا باجراء محادثات سلاما
بهدف استنزاف روسيا على حد تعبيره هذا
التقرير يعرض اهم ملامح مواقف الطرفين
بشان هذه المفاوضات
تستعد
لاستقبال سنه جديده وهما في حاله حرب
تقترب من اكمال عامها الاول يحل فصل
الشتاء وتنخفض درجات الحراره الى مستويات
قياسيه ما يعقد سعر المعارك في ارض
الميدان في ظل هذه الاجواء يتحدث الطرفان
عن المفاوضات مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
اليكسي ارستوفيتش جددت ثوابت بلاده وهي
استعاده وشبه جزيره القرم وكافه الاراضي
التي سيطرت عليها روسيا في المقابل بمثل
البيسكو المتحدث وباسم الكريمرن يقولوا
انه لا يمكن ان تكون هناك اي خطه سلام
اوكرانيا لا تاخذ بعين الاعتبار ما سماها
حقائق اليوم وهي ضم المناطق الاربع لروسيا
واضاف ان اي خطه لا تعترف بهذه الحقيقه لا
يمكن تسميتها خطه السلام ياتي هذا في سياق
زاد فيه الحديث عن المفاوضات قال الرئيس
الروسي الذيمر قبل ايام ان بلاده مستعده
للتفاوض مع كل اطراف الصراع بشان مقبوله
لكن هذه الاطراف ترفض ذلك واشار الى ان
جميع النزاعات المسلحه تنتهي بالدبلوماسيه
حديث بوتين عن حلول مقبول وعن الدبلوماسيه
فتح الباب على مصرعه لتكنات بشان مدى
استعداده لتسويه في اوكرانيا لكن السلطات
في كياب استقبلت هذه التصريحات بريبه
شديده وقالت انما تفعله القوات الروسيه في
الميدان يؤكد عكس ما يقوله المسؤولون
الروس وقدم وزير الخارج الاوكراني ديميتر
كوليبا تفاصيل خطه لعقد قمه سلام تحدث
سابقا قال ان افضل مكان لانعقاد قمه
السلام هو مقر الامم المتحده لكنه اشترت
موثوله روسيا امام محكمه جرائم حرب
للمشاركه فيها رده موسكو بسرعه بالتاكيد
على انها لن تشارك الا بشروطها قبل دم
روسيا اقاليموهانسكو
الماضي تحدث الرئيس الاوكراني شهره مارس
عن امكانيه التفاوض اذا انسحبت القوات
الروسيه من هذه المناطق ولم يشر الى وضع
شبه جزيره القرم لكن موقفه اصبح اكثر
تصلبا بعد قرار الدم واعلن انه لن يتفاوض
في وجود الرئيس بوتين قد يبدي زينسكي بعد
التصلب لكن موقفه يتاثر بمن يقدم له
مساعدات ضخمه خصوصا الولايات المتحده وقد
ذكرت الواشنطن بوست شهرا نوفمبر ان
الاداره الامريكيه طلبت منزلينسكي اظهار
بعض المرونه بشان المفاوضات حتى الان لا
يبدو من خلال مواقف الطرفين ان المفاوضات
ستبدا قريبا ويبقى انتظاره تطورات الوضع
في ارض المعركه وتاثير العقوبات الغربيه
على روسيا وقدره الغرب خصوصا واشنطن على
الاستمرار في دعم اكياس لمعرفه متى
ستعقدها هذه المفاوضات وباي شروط
ينضم الينا منبرمجها دون استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه برمجام سيد ديفيد يعني
كثر الحديث في الفتره الاخيره عن استعداد
كل طرف
للتفاوض هل نضجت الظروف الميدانيه
والسياسيه بهذا الاتجاه
ات للمفاوضات
للراي العالمي اكثر من كونها على انها
مؤشرات على احتماليه حقيقي حقيقيه لحدوث
مثل هذه
المفاوضات او ان يكون لها نتائج حقيقيه
وفعليه على الحرب
ماين كرافت
الاختلافات بين المواقف التفاضيه لكل طرف
وهذا ما يعني هذا في الواقع انه ليس هنالك
احتماليه حقيقيه
لنهايه القتال في اي وقت قريب يقال بان كل
طرف يعلي السقف قبل المفاوضات ما الذي
تحتاجه الامور لتصل الى
منحن دبلوماسيه يعني الرئيس بوتن يقول بان
كل النزاعات تنتهي بالدبلوماسيه
بوستات
يقولون ان الحرب بامكانها ان تنتهي اذا ما
انتهت حسب شروطهم شروطهم لا تتلاقى هي
منفصله عن بعضها البعض بشكل كبير في شهر
مارس كان هنالك ربما فرصه لي مفاوضات
حقيقيه لكن الان مواقف متباعده عن اي وقت
مضى بالتالي ما يقوله الاوكرانيون انه نعم
بامكاننا ان ندخل المفاوضات
عبر الامم المتحده هنالك تقطع في الصوت
المتين
ان يكون هنالك هنالك تقطع في الصوت من
المصدر لا يصل الى الترجمه
في الترجمه ويصل الصوت متقطع على كل
الاحوال شكرا لك سيد ديدون استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه
الحرب قال الكريم لان الرئيس الروسي لم
يتشاور مع اوبك كلاس قبل التوقيعه على
مرسوما يحضر تصدير النفط ومنتجاته من
روسيا وطاف تقوم بتحليل البضاعه بعد ادخال
الغرب سقفا لاسعار الغاز ومن السابق
لاوانه الحديث عن خطوات اخرى
[موسيقى]
قررت الجامعه العامه للنقل التابعه لاتحاد
العام التونسيه للشغل تنفيذ اضراب العام
في قطاع النقل بره وبحرا وجوا وذلك يومي
الخامس والعشرين والسادس والعشرين من
يناير المقبل وقال الكاتب العام للجامعه
في تصريحا اذا قرار الاضراب جاء نتيجه
تجاهل الحكومه لمطالب النقابيين ورفض
النقابيين التام للخصخصه في المؤسسات
العموميه لقطع النقل
في تونس وضمن تغطياتنا ايضا لاهم الاحداث
التي شهدها العام الجاري نوصلت الضوء على
الوضع في البلاد حيث توالت احداث المشهد
التونسي منذ الاجراءات التي اعلنها الرئيس
قيس سعيد في يوليو عام 2020 ابرز هذه
الاجراءات اقاله الحكومه تعليق عمل
البرلمان ودستور جديد في انتخابات تشريعيه
شهدت عزوفا كبيرا مسار في ظروف اجتماعيه
واقتصاديه صعبه نستعرض ابرز محطاته في هذا
العرض
[موسيقى]
اختلفت سنه 2022 عن سابقاتها بسرعه
الاحداث وتعدد القرارات الرئاسيه لاستكمال
خريطه الطريق التي وعد بها الرئيس التونسي
وقيس سعيد اثراء اجراءات استثنائيه السنه
الماضيه الانتخابات البرلمانيه التي جرت
في السابعه عشر من شهر ديسمبر كانت اخر
حلقه في خريطه الطريق المعلنه غير انها
كانت موضوع نقدا وتعليق من المعارضه
وهيئات محليه ودوليه مختصره في مراقبه
الانتخابات لم اتسمت به من ضعف في نسبه
المشاركه لم تتجاوز احد 10% وعدد النسبه
الاضعفه في تاريخ الانتخابات في تونس منذ
استقلالها في خمسينيات القرن الماضي
الاجراءات التي اعلنها الرئيس قيس سعيد
خلفت بدورها ردود فعل متباينه بين من
اعتبرها ضروره لاصلاح السياسي ومن راى
فيها تركيزا للحكم الفردي كالاستشاره حول
الدستور والنظام السياسي وحل المجلس
الاعلى للقضاء وعزل اكثر من 50 قاضيا وحلل
البرلمان ثم الاستفتاء على الدستور الذي
تلاه اصداره قانون انتخابيا جديد غير نظام
الاقتراع من التصويت على القوائم الحزبيه
الى التصويت على الافراد مع منع التمويل
الحكومي عن المرشحين
الاجراءات الرئاسيه حركه سواكن المعارضه
والمجتمع المدني فشلنا القضاه اضرابا عن
العمل مشروعا باعتصام واضرابا عن الطعام
لعدد منهم وكثافه المعارضه تحركاتها
الميدانيه مطالبه باسقات ما تسميه
الانقلاب
رفعوا المعارضه لنسق مطالبها قابلته
محاكمات سياسيه امام القضاء العسكري لعدد
من قادتها ولنواب من البرلمان المنحل
وليصحفينا ونشطاء مدنيين مشكله الرئيس قيس
سعيد لم تعد فقط مع اطراف معينه ومع
المعارضه وانما اصبحت مشكله الرئيس بشكل
جوهري واساسي مع المواطنين وخاصه
المواطنين الذين امنوا به واعطوه نوع من
التصوير
ازمه سياسيه ودستوريه تزامنت مع ازمه
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه توصف بالعميقه
والخطيره زادتها تازما الاوضاع الاقليميه
والدوليه جراء تداعيات الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه فكان انقطاع مواد اساسيه من
الاسواق بين الحين والاخر وغلاء الاسعار
وارتفاعه نسبه التضخم وغيرها من المظاهر
التي دفعت لاتحاد العام التونسي لشغل الى
شني اضراب عام خلال شهر يونيو حزيران
الماضي للمطالبه بحلول توقف نزيف الازمه
وتراعي القدره الشرائيه الشغالين مثل ما
يقولوا الاتحاد
سنه 2022 انه اييي احتدت الازمه خاصه انه
في ظل غياب قرارات شجاعه من السلطه
التنفيذيه لاخذ يعني الاجراءات اللازمه
والتي هي كذلك تصب فيما يطلبه صندوق النقد
الدولي وهذه اجراءات ضروريه سنه تتلوها
اخرى يعتبرها الرئيس قيس سعيد من عرجا
تاريخيا في مقاومه الفساد واسترجاع
الاموال المنهوبه سابقا الى خزينه الدوله
في حين يتوقع الخبراء الاقتصاديون انها
ستكون سيئه لتراجع الانتاج وشح الموارد
الماليه لخزينه الدوله
سامع اليوم وتعتبرها المعارضه سنه الحزم
مع اختلاف في اوساطها بين المطالبين برحيل
ما يعتبرونهم قلبا وبدايه صفحه جديده وبين
المنادينا بحوار وطني شامل ينزع فتيل
الازمه على مختلف الاصعده لطفي حجي
الجزيره تونس
انضم الينا من تونس احمد نجيب الشابي رئيس
جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه اهلا بك يا سيد احمد
سيد احمد اضراب جديد
للجامعه العامه للنقل الى اين تتجه الامور
على المستوى السياسي والاقتصادي
والاجتماعي في تونس
الازمه في تونس تتساعد
وتتسارع بشكل خطير الاضراب الذي قرره
اليوم الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل في
قطاع النقل من نتائج المباشره شل الحركه
في البلاد لان النقل يمثل الشرايين الحياه
الاجتماعيه اذا ما تعطل النقل تعطلت كل
الاعمال لكن هذا الاضراب ياتي في السياق
سياق تصاعد الغضب قبل
اقل من اسبوع اصدر الاتحاد العام للشغل
بيان
ارتقى فيه الى ضروره حل الازمه السياسيه
في البلاد لم يعد يكتفي بالمطالب
الاجتماعيه في نفس الوقت صدر عن المحامين
لائحه باجماع كل فروع هيئه المحامين في
تونس في الجمهوريه التونسيه ترفع سقف
مطالبها الى ضروره التنسيق مع المنظمات
الوطنيه للبحث عن مخرج من الازمه في نفس
الوقت القضاه الذين اضربوا لمده شهرين
واعتقد البعض انهم تاثروا معنويا عقدوا
اجتماع لجمعيه القضاه التونسيين في نهايه
الاسبوع واصدر بيانا لا يقل حده حول
اوضاعهم واوضاع البلاد كل هذا ياتي في
سياق الفشل الذري الذي لما
السلطه بعد نتائج انت
الانتخابات الماضيه 17 ديسمبر حيث اكثر من
90% حسب الارقام الرسميه قاطعوها ولذلك ما
اقوله زد على ذلك الفشل في اداره العلاقات
الخارجيه
واهم ما يذكر ان صندوق نقد الدولي رغم من
الحكومه قبلت بكل شروطه اعتذر عن تمويدها
لانه لم يجد في الوضع الاجتماعي والوضع
السياسي ما يفيد الاستقرار والامكانيه
الذهاب في الاسلام
بالنسبه
الى عمق الزجاجه ما وصفته بالفشل كيف يمكن
مواجهته ما هي الخيارات امام المعارضه
اليوم وهي لم تتوحد الى حد الان في تونس
اولا بنسبه الينا في جبهه الخلاص الوطني
على اساس معينه هذه الاوضاع اصبح واضعا
واضحا بان تونس لم تعد تحتمل
مزيد من المعاناه وتفاقم الازمنه لانه
يهدد بالانفجار وحتى بالفوز ولذلك نحن
اقترحنا ان نمر مباشره الى انتخابات
الرئاسيه مبكره السيد قيس سعيد فشله اولا
تخلى عن كل التزاماته وكل القسم الذي
اقسمه لاحترام الدستور وانقلب على كل
المؤسسات الى اخره لا فائده في العوده الى
ذلك اذا فشل في مساله السياسي فشله في
اداره الشان الاقتصادي فشل في اداره
العلاقات الخارجيه يجب ان يذهب لذلك نحن
نطلب برحيله عبر انتخابات الرئاسيه مباشره
عفوا كل المعارضات في ذات اليوم اصدرت
بيانات في نفس الاتجاه اذا المعارضه بعد
لم توحد صفوفها لكن تشخيصها واهدافها هي
ذاتها والمهم هو ان تتحرك
اذا كان التشخيص والاهداف هي نفسها ولكن
كيفيه الوصول اليها دعوتم الى انتخابات
الرئاسيه مبكره ولكن لا يبدو بان الرئيس
سعيد يلقي بالا لهذه الدعوات بل يقول
بانهضن في الاستحقاقات الانتخابيه المقبله
الرئيس قيس سعيد ماضي في طريقه وهو طريق
مسدود
والان الاوضاع تتطور نحو حراك شعبي من اجل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه سابقه لاولها لا
استبعد اطلاقا مع تاثير الازمه الاجتماعيه
تاخذ المظاهرات حجما اضخم بكثير تذكر
بالحرائق الجزائري من اجل اسقاط العهده
الخامسه هذا احد الاحتمالات وهو الافضل
لانه تطور سلمي مؤثر من طرف منظمه النقبيه
والمهنيه والاحزاب السياسيه حتى لو لم يكن
له راس واحد ولكن يمكن ان تذهب الامور في
اتجاه الانفجار الذي لا يتحكم فيه احد
وهنا ستجد الدوله العميقه همم او الدوله
الصلبه نفس انا بخيار اما ان تواجه
المواطنين دون افق وليون او انها ستنحاز
الى المطلب الشعبي باقاله الرئيس واجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
عن حراك شعبي ولكن الاتحاد العام للشغل
وهو المحرك الاساسي على الرغم انه يقول
بان الحل يجب ان يكون سياسيا الا انه يرى
بان تحركاته هي مطلبيه بالاساس ويتح-
ويتحدث عن حوار
نعم بالضبط ملاحظتك سليمه تماما الاتحاد
انتقل من المطالب بالفئويه يعني التي تخص
منظوره في زياده في الاجور في احترام
الاتفاقات بينه وبين الحكومه الى اخره الى
مرحله اخرى هو طرح الازمه العامه في تونس
وضروره حوار وطني وتحرك في اتجاه
المنظمات الوطنيه لايجاد حل الا انه
بالفعل لم يرتقي الان الى طرح مساله اقاله
رئيس الجمهوريه والذهاب الى انتخابات
الرئاسيه لكن هذا شيء
ينتهي اليه كل كل فئات في المجتمعات
التونسي لانه ضروري تفرضها الاوضاع تفرضها
تلافي الانهيار ولذلك اعتقد بان التحركات
في الشارع التي ينوي تنظيمها الاتحاد
العام التونسي الشغل ستكون رافض من روافد
التغيير والامور تجري دافقت حسب ارادتي
الاطراف الفاعله وانما حسب اليات وقواعد
وقوانين التطور الاجتماعي والسياسي شكرا
لك من تونس نجيب الشاذلي جبهه الخلاص
الوطني
وينضم الينا ايضا من تونس عميد المحامين
التونسيين السابق ابراهيم بودرباله سيد
ابراهيم بودرباله استمعنا الى سيد نجيب
الشابي وهو يقول بان انتخابات رئاسيه
مبكرا هي ضروره حتميه لتلافي الانهيار
والله
اعتقد ان هذا المطلب ااا
غير صادر عن الشعب التونسي باكمله الشعب
التونسي باكمله لا زال مساند للرئيس قيس
سعيد لما ليلاحدهم من نمره الصدق في
افعاله واقواله وتصرفته على اي حال
صديقي وزميلي الاستاذ نجيب الشابي لو سمحت
يعني اذا كان الشعب يؤيد الرئيس سعيد كما
تقولون كيف تفسرون الاقبال الضعيف جدا على
الانتخابات التي جرت وان كان الرئيس قد
وصفها بانها لحظه مفصليه وتاريخيه
اولا بالذات هذه اول انتخابات ذات مصداقيه
لان الانتخابات مثل ما تفضلتي وذكرت في
السابق يعني منذ الاستقلال الى الان لم
تجري انتخابات نزيهه ففي ظل حكم
المجاد الاكبر لحبيب بورقيبه رحمه الله
كانت دائما الانتخابات مزوره كذلك في ظل
حكم الرئيس الاسبق زين العابدين بن علي
رحيم والله كانت الانتخابات مزوره وبعد
اربعه تجافي كان هناك المال الفاسد الذي
لعب دورا هاما فضلا على همم يعني تجميع
المساويتين بوسائل نقل همم مجانيه
ويعني همم
من شانه ان يدفعهم نحو التسويه الان
الانتخابات يشهد العالم كامل لان هاني
انتخابات نزيه ولا ايه الانتخابات اتت
ارقامها وهي قام الذي
يسمع انا لم اشكرك في الارقام انا سالت عن
النسبه بالتحديد النسبه حوالي 11 في المئه
هل هذه النسبه
وهي النسبه الصحيحه لكن لكن لا يمكن ان
تدعي المعارضه وان هذه النسبه يعني وان
بقيه من لم يسود يساند المعارضه هذه الامر
غير صحيح البتاع ما وقع هو ان الكثير من
التونسيين اصبحوا الان نتيجه حاله المعيشه
والنتيجه همم انحدار القدره الشهيره هي
هناك نوع من العزوف فضلا على ان
البرلمانات السابقه اعطت صوره سيئه
بالنسبه للشعب التونسي ويعتقدون وان
المسجد البرلماني هذا السيء همم ااا لابد
من من يعني من تغييره وبالتالي يعني رفظهم
ل- وعزوفهم عن المشاركه في الانتخابات هو
النذر هو جاء نتيجه للصوره التي اعطاها
البرلمان السابق لكن لو اننا ناخذ يعني
صادقه
لنقارن بين نسبه انتخاب الرئيس السيد
ونسبه المشاركه في التسويق على الدستور
فلزيدها همم
انما قل وان نسبه المشاركه في الدستور
هيرفي لو سمحت
ياتي لو سمحت يعني فيما يتعلق بان العزوف
ياتي نتيجه الصوره السلبيه التي اعطتها
البرلمانات السابقه ولكن اليوم نتحدث عن
دستور جديد وضعه الرئيس سعيد عن قانون
انتخاب جديد وضعه الرئيس السعيد ان كان
الشعب التونسي يؤيد الرئيس سعيد الذي وصف
هذه الانتخابات بانها مفصليه وتاريخيه
لماذا لم ينزل الى التصويت هنا سؤالي
بالتحديد قبل ما ننتقل الى نقطه اخرى
همم
من شارك في التصويت برهنوا على وطنيه
عاليه نظرا للظروف التي يعيشها الشعب
التونسي اليوم من اا ذا في القدره الشرعيه
من همم ندره المواد الحياتيه ومن يعني
المحاولات التي همم
يرمونها من وراها الى اثاره غضب الشعب
التونسي وذلك باحتكار يعني المواد
الاساسيه الحياتيه سواء يعني السكر او زيت
او القهوه
يعني الحليب ماده الحليب التي احتكروها كل
ذلك لاثاره غضب الشعب التونسي لكن هذا
العزوف الذي تم هو رساله توجه لرئيس
الدوله والحكومه لكن لا يعني بضروره وان
همم عامه الشعب التونسي فقدوا الثقه في
رئيس ولذلك باستكمال السادس
ضعف القدره الشرائيه والاقليم
عشان اكثر من مره الى ضعف القدره الشرائيه
ما الذي فعله الرئيس التونسي من اجل تحسين
الوضع الاقتصادي
ويعني المفاوضات مع صندوق النقد نفسه
متعثره
لم تكون البلاد في احسن حال عندما اعلن
الرئيس تدبير 25 جويريه هبت سراح كبيره من
الشعب التونسي لمسان يعني يتدابير التي
اتخذها ثم عندما يعني حدد خانه الطريق
احترم كل الاجزال سواء الاستشاري
الالكترونيه اول حوار او مشروع الدستور او
الاستفتاء حول الدستور وبالتالي فمثلت
احترام الازال لها قيمه هامه ثم المسداقيه
التي اعطتها الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
فضلا على ان هناك دور ثاني بالنسبه
للانتخابات يتعلق بمياه 31 داير انتخابيه
واكيد يعني الحكم النهائي سيكون على اساس
يعني نسبه التسويه في الدوره الثانيه ان
النسبه ضعيفه لماذا لانه هناك دوائر فيها
مرشحه واحد وهناك يعني
سؤالك
فقط لذلك
دقيقه ابراهيم ابو بدر بلا عميد المحامين
التونسيين السابقون تما معانا من تونس
[موسيقى]
للاسبوع الثالث على التوالي تواصل الاقليه
الصربيه شمال كسوفو اغلاق الطرق المؤديه
الى مناطقها بالشاحنات والحواجز رغم تلويح
حكومه بريشتينا بانها جاهزه للتحرك وانهاء
هذا الوضع ياتي هذا في وقت تستمر فيها
حاله تجذبات والتبادل الاتهامات بين
كوسوفو وصربيا رغم دعواته والمناشدات
الدوليه بالتهدئه ووقف التصعيد
رغم افراج السلطات كوسوفو عن الشرطي
المنتمي للاقليه الصربيه الذي تسبب
اعتقاله في العاشر من ديسمبر الجاري
بتفاقم بحاله التوتر الشماليه البلاد
وصولا الى ازمه مفتوحه مع صربيا فان
تصاعدي المخاوف من تفجر الاوضاع هناك لا
يزال حاضرا في ظل اغلاق المحتاجين صرب
لاكبر معبر حدود مع جارتهم الجنوبيه
واستمرار اغلاق الطرقات الرئيسيه بالقوه
من قبل الاقليه الصربيه الشماليه كونسوفو
تبدو حكومه مصممه على المضيء بعيدا في
مساعها لفرض السياده على كل اراضيها في
الوقت الذي منحته لقوات حفظ السلام لكي
تتحرك ينفذ بسرعه وهي تعلن انها لن
تتسامحها مع من وضع الحواجز على الطرق
وستواصل النشره المزيد من وحدات الشرطه
شماليه البلاد ولن تتحدث او تتعاون مع من
وصفتهم بالمجرمين بل ستعتقلهم
موقف ياتي بعد قرار الرئيس الصربي وضع
الجيش في حاله تاهب القصوى وزياره وزير
الدفاع الصربي الى قاعده عسكريه قريبه من
الحدود مع كوسوفو وعلى ما يبدو فان ترد
العلاقات بين الغرب وروسيا بسبب الحرب على
اوكرانيا يلقي بظلاله على المشهد غربي
البلقان اذ سبق لوزير الداخليه الكوسوفي
ان اتهم الصربيا بالسعي لزعزعه استقرار
بلاده بتوجيه من روسيا لكنه موسكو صارت
بنا في الاتهامات بتاجيج التوتر وان اكد
الناطق باسم الكرملين دعم بلاده ببالغراد
في ازماتها الراهنه مع بريشتينا في حين
اعربت الخارجيه الامريكيه والاتحاد
الاوروبي عن قلقهما ازاء استمرار التوتري
في شمال كسوفو وذكر بيان المشترك ان
الجانبين يعملان مع جميع الاطراف لايجاد
حل سياسيا للتوتر والاتفاق على خريطه طريق
صالح الاستقرار في بقى منذ انفصلت كوسوفو
عن صربيا عام
1999 وحتى بعد ان اعلنت استقلالها عام
2008 ما زالت صربيا تعدها جزءا من اراضيها
وتدعم الاقليه الصربيه فيها ففي الاجزاء
الشماليه من كوسوفو يعيش نحو 50 الف صربي
ويرفضون الاعتراف بها دوله مستقله او
بحكومتها وينظرون الى بلغراد على انها
عاصمه لهم تصاعد التوتر بين الجارتين منذ
ان حاولت حكومه بريشتينا الزام الصربي في
اجزائها الشماليه باستبدال لوحات السيارات
التي يعود تاريخها الى ما قبل حرب كوسوفو
باخرى من اصدار محلي ما تسبب باستقالات
جماعيه للصربي من الشرطه ثم ازداد الوضع
احتقانا بعد اعتقال شرطي سابق من صربي
كوسوفو ليرد الصرب باقامه حواجز على الطرق
ورفض الانسياع لمطالب حكومه كوسوفو
بازالتها
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى خبر مرسوم الرئيس الروسي لحظر
لتوليد النفط والمنتجات النفطيه للدول
التي فرضت سقفا على الاسعار خلط الاوراق
هذا القرار مجددا في سوق الطاقه العالميه
ويدخل القرار حيث التنفيذ في الاول من
فبراير
2023 ويستمر لمده خمسه اشهر نذكر بالدول
المعنيه بقرار الحذر وهي دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي التي تبلغ صادرات روسيا النفطيه
اليها نحو 45 في المئه كما يظهر مجموعه
الدول السبعه الكبرى التي تضم الولايات
المتحده بريطانيا فرنسا وايضا المانيا
وايطاليا وكندا واليابان من الموافقين على
وضعه حد اقصى لسعر النفط الروسي المنقول
بحرا عندها 60 دولارا للبرميل تصدر روسيا
10 في المئه من منتجاتها النفطيه الى
السوق الامريكيه استراليا ايضا من
المنضمين الى حلف تحديد سقف لاسعار الطاقه
وتعتمد بدرجه اقل على واردات الطاقه من
روسيا 90% من شحنات النفط العالميه يجري
تامينها من قبل شركات في مجموعه الدول
السبع ما يعني ان نقله نفط الروسيه خارج
خصوم موسكو سيكون معقدا جدا ذكرت وكاله
بلو برج الامريكيه النواتير تتحول صادرات
روسيا من النفط الخام الى اسيا تزايدت في
الاشهر الاخيره ابدا يتجه ثلثاء نفط الخام
منقول عبر ناقلات في موانع الروسيه الان
الى اسيا بينما كانت النسبه تقل عن 50%
قبل اندلاع حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا من شان
القدره الاسيويه على امتصاص نحو نصف حجم
الصادرات الخام الروسي المنقوله بحرا وهي
5000 برميل يوميا تضاف الى مليوني برميل
وهي حجم الصادرات النفطيه اليوميه
الاساسيه تتجه الانذار الى مسافه تكرير
الصينيه التي سجلت نشاطا ملحوظا في الاونه
الاخيره فيما اعلنت الهند انها ستواصل
شراء مشتقات النفط الروسيه شكلت صادرات
النفط الروسيه
22% من اجمالي واردات الهند من الخام
مسجله
946,000 برميل يوميا خلال شهر اكتوبر
الماضي ينضم الينا من لندن الخبير في شؤون
الطاقه مصطفى الباذركان اهلا بك سيد مصطفى
سيد مصطفى كيف يمكن ان يؤثر القرار الروسي
على اسعار النفط وسوق
طبعا اسعار النفط احتوت هذا القرار ولذلك
لم يكن القرار يعني يصل الى درجه مهمه
لماذا لان القرار تم اتخاذه مسبقا من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول كما ذكرتم في
تقريركم و الفارق انه هو ثلاثه ايام
الرابع من شباط سيكون هناك ايقاف لاستيراد
مشتقات النفط الروسي والرئيس بوتن همم قرر
انه الاول من شباط هذه نقطه النقطه
الثانيه لابد من ذكرها وهي انه هناك تراجع
يعني قبل اربعه ايام او خمسه ايام كان
هناك تصريح لوزير الطاقه الروسي لوح انه
روسيا قد تخفض انتاجها بخمسه الى سبعه
بالمئه من انتاجها الذي يتجاوز 10 مليون
البرميل ولكن ذلك لم يحصل كانت قرار
المرسوم لماذا انا براي شخص انه لم يكون
هناك موافقه من دول المنتجه لنفط خاصه
اوبك بلس التي همم يعني
اوكي تحالف مع روسيا لماذا هذا خفض لم
يتزوج ما اعطيك كلاس يعني يقول بانه لم
يتشاور مع اوبك بلس
صحيح لم يتشهر ولكن بالتاكيد يعرف الراي
ال- ال- ال- ال-
الجانب الاخر ولذلك تراجع عن هذا القرار
وكان الاقرار بهذا المرسوم هذا المرسوم
همم فيه ثلاثه نقاط مهمه اولا همم عمليه
تحويل همم الاسواق وايجاد اسواق بديله همم
روسيا منذ اشهر بدات تسترجع ناقلات النفط
من ايران ومن فنزويلا وهي بحدود الاكثر من
100 ناقله نفط كانت تستخدمها ايران
للالتفاف على العقوبات وكذلك فنزويلا
وبدات تستخدمها من اجل ايجاد اسواق مدينه
في جنوب شرق اسيا هذه نقطه النقطه الثانيه
حينما يقول الرئيس بوتن انه هذا المرسوم
لديه امكانيه في عدم شمول دوله او عده دول
بهذا القرار وهو يقصد في شك وحده الاتحاد
الاوروبي لماذا لان هناك دول ترفض هذا
القرار على سبيل المثال المجرم النقطه
الثالثه والاهم حينما يحدد خمس اشهر ست
اشهر بمعنى ينتظر اجتماع الصيفي لمنظمه
اوبك بلس طيب يعني موفقه تقديراتك مع وجود
اسواق جديد تتوجه اليها روسيا هل ستتاثر
عائدات روسيا من النفط بهذا القرار
بالتاكيد تراجع السعر يعني روسيا اليوم
مدخولها في شهر نوفمبر من مبيعات النفط
شهريا 20 مليار دولار مع تراجع النقطه لا
ننسى انه كما ذكرتهم في تقرير
المتميز انه الصين همم هل هند تستورد لنفط
الروسي بخفض 35 دولار من البرميل الصين
كذلك حتى الغاز تحصل على 25% خفض سيكون
هناك خفض اضافي بالتاكيد لماذا هو مساله
العرض والطلب في تراجع مدخول روسيا من من
النفط ولكن هل ذلك سيؤثر على اسعار النفط
العالميه
قبل في اسعار النفط سيد مصطفى الاسعار
بالنسبه للهند والصين ولكن هناك هنالك
ازدياد في الكميات هذه زياده في الكميات
لا تعادل النقص في الاسعار او الحسم الذي
تقدمه روسيا لكل من الهند والصين
صحيح ولكن لا ننسى انه الهند والصين هناك
شركات تستثمر في ذلك النفط الخام الصين
الهندي حد هذا اليوم تستورد النفط الروسي
بتخفيض وتعيد تكريره وتبيع اكثر من مليون
برميل من منتجات النفط المكرره الى شركات
في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي فهذا معناه تحصل
على نفط مخفض ولكنه تبيعه بالاسعار
العالميه هذا سياتي تحت طائره
نفط الروسي مصطفى
اياته حصاد الليله الى جمله منتصف الليل
مع حسن وائل